do you truly in your heart of hearts
truly believe that this is a human being
this without a doubt without a doubt yes
this is a dolphin fetus
without a doubt a dolphin fetus is a
human being this is
[Music]
you mentioned one of my
all-time favorite charlie kirk pieces of
content that you are in you it it is it
is a very famous piece of content i
actually think gabe we've probably
played it on our podcast i don't know
three or four times i [ __ ] hate
charlie it's a it's it is definitely an
evergreen type of uh piece of content
i love that yeah i hope that clip never
leaves him it's the dolphin fetus clip
it it is the dolphin fetus clip and i
think people have have watched it i'm
going to show it again here um really
quick because i just i just want people
to remember exactly what the what the
clip is but
i i have a few questions about this clip
and the reason why is because we've had
another friend of the show rachel
bittikoffer went and she went to debate
night or whatever that i think that's
yeah that's what he calls a debate
with charlie kirk he she went and
debated him and she sent me the footage
and i was like hmm that's kind of funny
and here's the reason why i have a
question because i wonder did he
intentionally send you this footage that
you were able to
you know make into a clip or
is this part of he actually put this in
that debate night like he put it in
well listen i'm a very strong negotiator
it's part of being the mad king is not
taking not letting other people set your
terms and so uh when he reached out to
me you know he famously reached out to
congressman eric swalwell
and he offered him to be on debate night
and swalwell instead put his dm on blast
and said i'm not going to go and debate
an insurrectionist that makes me and my
family unsafe
i instead accepted the exact same dm
that charlie slid into mine with and
said i'm gonna go debate an
insurrectionist and humiliate them
and
uh do what i can to make sure this
person is weakened um because they are
an enemy of the people anybody that
that supports turning over an obviously
fair election
and did so by sending buses of people
there and encouraging them to fight
uh deserves to be
taken down and you know
there are people that even don't want
this special to be
heard i was telling you guys off air but
i don't care i'll announce it on air my
facebook page was as was was hacked
taken away from me stolen got recovered
last night and was just stolen again
this morning there are forces that don't
want you to see this special and
we cannot let them i will not let them
i've worked too hard for this
and um we need to get you know
some of the truth and keeping these
idiots these male-intended [ __ ]
honest and so
not that my special's gonna do you know
gonna change anything on the grand
scheme but we all need to be talking
speaking our truth and speaking truth to
power as much as we can and every little
bit counts
um so i negotiated very strongly with
charlie's people that they had to allow
me to shoot my own
iphone footage of the whole debate oh
wow so this so this actual this clip
came from your iphone so what you're
saying is is charlie did cut this out of
no version no i also made them promise
that i would not do it unless they
agreed to cut out zero content unless
there was just like dead error and so
they had to agree to that in writing
and they did
and so um they released it but what they
did do sneakily at the end of the debate
in the bonus time
um
they did cut out the bonus time where i
then call him out on funding the
insurrection attempt and the protests at
the ellipse or rather approach loops
that led to the insurrection and i got
him to storm off of his own show and
storm off of his own set did you ever
did you so they cut that they cut that
out i that's on my full debate on
myyoutube.combeegleeb
you can see the whole debate's an hour
20 it's the extra 15 minutes that we do
that shows that happen and because i
released it and released a separate meme
showing that and so he was forced to
then show it he then uploaded a second
version of the whole debate that did
include that so he could pretend like he
didn't cut it out right he definitely
did cut it out because both versions are
still live and the second version he
called me so-called comedian and that's
the title
you put me on your show bro what does
that speak to your own booking ability
if you're so called but my favorite part
of the charlie kirk negotiations not
only did i get all those details set so
that i knew i would be protected and
that i could post all these clips as
much as i want but i further got them to
agree to fly me out to a studio in
arizona put me up in a dope hotel give
me a car service and pay for all of my
meals when i was there so right after i
was kicked out of his studio and
security escorted me off after i made
charlie run like a baby off his own set
i still had a car service the rest of
the day just wait take me and my
girlfriend now fiance to a very nice
sushi restaurant arizona and we had a
270 dollar sushi dinner on charlotte
oh my god did you know i thought i
thought i thought that this dolphin
fetus piece of content was the best
piece of content but right now in this
moment that story that you're telling is
a damn good piece of charlie kerr
conference you realize that the mad king
strikes again
what's that i said the mad king strikes
again that's right man and and aside
from that one meme too if you don't
watch the whole debate we released on my
instagram as a little christmas gift to
everybody during the holidays last year
12 days of kirk's and ass and
every day we released a new meme where i
own him from that debate all the topic
of abortion a great topic for the
holidays isn't it oh absolutely well i
i'd like to get into the uh abortion
abortion um uh subject nobody's getting
into my uterus you understand that
let's let's watch let's watch the uh the
famous
charlie kirk getting schooled on
abortion in 15 seconds
do you truly in your heart of hearts
truly believe that this is a human being
this without a doubt without a doubt yes
this is a dolphin fetus
without a doubt a dolphin fetus is a
human being this is a human being
but
quite differently
you just confirmed that a dolphin in
life you confuse dolphins for human
babies often so let me go to sea world
and you're like somebody's got human
babies in that aquarium ben
did you have this whole thing prepared
and you knew you were going to strike or
you do you just carry a little
brown bag full of uh dolphins
pictures
i usually do carry a brown bag of
dolphin fetuses that's just my sexual
kink it's the only way i can come but
um i happened to bring it to this
location because i had that moment
planned i knew exactly how i wanted to
phrase it i knew exactly how i wanted to
give him fairly a chance to say yes or
no that he believed that was a a human
or not i wasn't trying to trap him but i
had an exact way to phrase it where i
said to him
i showed the i plan to show the photo to
the audience and then to him and say do
you and your heart of hearts believe and
he said yes i gave him an out i said
i
i said you do or whatever i said i give
i said do you believe in your heart of
hearts this is a human being and he goes
without a doubt and i go without a doubt
i give him a chance
he could have doubted at that moment
i think so i can't tell the photo right
he goes yes
absolutely and so i talk about it in my
special as well um and a little bit of
of of the behind the scenes of that um
because uh he is a
bad person